[Music]
anybody here a fan of jk rowling oh yeah
she cool
oh yeah she's cool i like her movies i
never read her books but harry potter
though come on
that's that's her right i hope that's
yeah that's her yeah but you never read
her voice but like come on i know she
was just trying to get there people were
like canceling her for being like like
anti-trans or something like that right
was she being anti-trainers she's been
putting out some trans sentiment or
something i don't know i'm only a fan of
one jk which one is it bud jim carr
[Laughter]
harry with the k yeah
john kerry
so um
jk rowling
has very very recently been tricked by
russian pranksters into thinking she was
on a zoom call with president zillin's
go ahead you're the russian do the call
as a russian mm-hmm you're so good at
that i'm not good at russian he's good
at germany i'm gonna get a german i
think i could do german try russian
let's just see we're going to find jk
rowling
we're going to do a zoom call with jk
rowling uh we are going to see if you
could donate some money to me mr
zielinski that's how it goes
and they're like she's like i'm in i'm
totally in yeah hagrid and that's about
it we love it
is our favorites uh
yeah so we love the movies
you guys have access to chocolate frogs
wait proud of all the [ __ ] accents
why the german i know no and i've never
oh you know why the germans i don't know
do it do a little sexy i like it when
you do it all sexy yeah
fabulous
seductive style scam yeah you're trying
to like like like seduce her into
signing uh
[Laughter]
uh uh you're jk rowling okay yeah he
needs a character hi uh we are going to
see if you could donate some money we're
trying to collect some funds for the uh
ukrainian efforts uh
sexier no you have uh connections with
zilensky we are wondering if you could
send some money for us how much do you
need uh maybe one and a half 2.2 million
dollars uh we are going to
need these kind of funds for that's your
second sexier dude
i'm trying to be sexy
[Laughter]
oops
now we are talking pieces
there we go and there we go
you know but i want two oops
either side
yeah that's it there it is so harry
potter author jk rowling has fallen
victim to a fake zoom call by russian
pranksters pretending to be the
president the uh edited june 18th video
shows rowling being fooled
by russian comedy duo woven and lexus oh
the prank
involving who have made a name for
themselves for prank calling celebrities
including prince harry elton john and
george w bush how did they get
well is it really hard
oh
are they like a sasha bear and colin
we're like they're really good or
allergy maybe maybe
rowling was under the impression she
would be speaking to the ukrainian
president about her charity work during
the 12-minute clip the famous author was
asked a series of awkward questions
rowling was told by the comedy duo that
they were scrolling the curse avada
kadavra from her harry potter series on
the sides of ukrainian missiles
oh my they also asked what uk prime
minister boris johnson's true gender is
oh no and question if dumbledore is
really gay and who the hogwarts
headmaster had slept with
they say hopefully not with the
transgender the duo said referencing the
author's ongoing um trans community kind
of issue i kind of dunked on her vulva
and alexis also asked the airport author
if she would change harry's lightning
bolt scar in future copies of her best
selling series as they claimed it
closely resembles the russian military z
which has been printed on kremlin tanks
that's a bad one and she said i will
look into that rolling replied she added
it might be good for me to do something
with that myself on social media because
i think that will get into the
newspapers
roland's charity lumos has been
providing aid to children and families
in ukraine the prankster seized on this
encouraging the harry potter author to
send weapons instead of aid
that's aid
quote i want to clarify where you are
sending them uh the money that lumos has
collected volvin alexis asks the the
best-selling writer
we want to buy a lot of weapons and
missiles with your money to destroy
russian troops i hope you're all for
that oh my god rolling replies
we'll look after the kids but i really
want ukraine to have all the arms it
needs
representatives for the harry potter
author have now lashed out at the prank
dubbing it distasteful
jk was approached to talk about her
extreme charitable or extensive
charitable work in ukraine supporting
children and families who have been
affected by the current conflict in the
region the video which has been edited
is a distorted representation they just
took out all the substance and just got
the funny
the funny parts i mean it's a prank
untasteful how how did they go so like
they asked so many questions that like
not one of them was like this is weird
for a president to be talking but a lot
of these guys if if they're good
it's the way that they lead up to it
where it's like building up it's not
like out of like left field you know and
then it's like okay how about this
trailer
[Laughter]
how do you think about you know when you
give weapons of mass destruction you
know that's a good ukrainian don't be
like you crazy you're [ __ ] pranking
me you can't go you can't do it that way
you got to be like so
what's the weather like in the ukraine
you know it's good oh that's a good one
that's a good one
what's the weather he's asking what's
the weather like to jk there's no water
like in ukraine where i'm from small
talk right and then you bait them into
small talk and then they'll be like yeah
yeah it goes
i heard it's acid rain and then it's
like
oh really yeah you sound so evil yeah
from the missiles yes it goes yeah yeah
there's a lot of missiles there oh you
agree there's missiles yeah the ukraine
should have missiles on and she goes
yeah they need to protect themselves
gotcha [ __ ] did it mean like it's like
that i'm really good at baiting people
in these tactics i just i'm i was a spy
in my past life
did anybody did you guys i know steve's
not here but did you guys ever pull
pranks on people we're not good i'm not
good we break characters so fast i'm
like yeah that's me man the whole time
that's me too did you try it you did try
didn't you ever tell us about the story
i tried to prank my mom
[Laughter]
you want to tell the story what is this
so like back in like 2012
i signed up for my first uh powerlifting
meet before like product thing was
really like a big thing right and then
um
i called my mom cause i wanted her to be
there actually and i was like hey mom do
this part of the thing what do you think
and then she's like what no dude that's
that's crazy she said dude i was there
yeah and then i'll and then i forgot
what happened but we end up hanging up
and then i think i called her like maybe
like a week later and i'm like hey mom
i'm gonna do the policy meet soon are
you gonna come and then she was like i
talked to my fortune teller friends
and they said you're gonna break your
back
so don't do it and i was like
all right
so i didn't invite her obviously i
trained for it and then i competed
and then when i called her the next time
um oh yeah i called her hey mom i
competed in the powerlifting and she was
like oh
and then she's like did you break her
back and i'm like i have to come see you
and she's like okay
so
we i borrowed the neck brace from inside
the bathroom and then we borrowed the
wheelchair from her monk jetta extra
wheelchair in in the garage
and then so we put we put it in the suv
and i told her i was like you have to
drive
and with the whole character work has to
start from before my mom's one of those
people as soon as like she hears like
someone in the front yard she's like
she's really looking out the window and
she's like what's going on you know so i
like i we can't miss a step so i'm like
baby can't break character don't [ __ ]
break characters it's gonna be awesome
i was against the whole thing so i'm
sitting stupid you provided the
wheelchair
i did none of that i'm saving the
driver's seat neck brace on everything
and then she goes we arrive in front of
my mom's house she pulls out the
wheelchair and then she like helps me
get out of the pathway no i would like
the accomplice there no no i was in the
car parked and i thought we were all
gonna get out and do whatever the [ __ ]
right he goes what are you doing you
have to open the door for me and i'm
like why it was because
i broke my back and i'm like god damn it
so yeah you didn't commit
so she gets me in the wheelchair and
then she wheels me to the front of the
house i have my neck brace on like this
and then uh i think she rings the
doorbell and then my mom has one of
those doors where it's like a metal gate
right and then the wooden door behind it
so you see the wooden door open
and then you just see her silhouette and
in her silhouette it's just like
oh [ __ ] he broke his back didn't he the
fortune tellers were right as soon as
she opened the door i couldn't contain
any more other
[Laughter]
laughing i couldn't
her eyes were like she was on the verge
of crying really
[ __ ] trash dude did you say anything
to her afterwards i said i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry it was not my idea at all
you know your [ __ ] son you know what
you raised woman
how did you just do get get up and then
is she like your bag is broken be
careful yeah the whole day should still
ask me are you sure are you sure i'm
like yes so she believes the fortune
teller more than you yeah
even when you took off the brace got out
of a wheelchair walked in laughed and
did a backflip yeah trips breaks his
back
stepped on a crack knew it
yeah she was yeah she believes her
fortune child that much
has the fortune teller ever been like
right i don't know sometimes they are
but then she she knows like 20 of them
so i don't know which one she's talking
about
even even a blind squirrel will find a
nut once in a while yeah
confucius say confucius
[Music]
you